I'm Holly Gregory I'm a partner in the
international law firm of Sibley Austin
today we're talking about each and every
business deal from HBO's succession
what's gang up on Dad and take him down
who's really behind me just take the
money me wrong take on that do not do
this you have to be a killer
acquisitions
in the very first episode we see Kendall
going to vaulter a social media company
to explore acquiring them way star has
been very slow to Pivot into the social
media digital media space and the
easiest way to remain relevant is to
acquire a company that already has built
that capacity and that's what valter is
I think Walter is the shiz but it
becomes very clear early on that
Lawrence isn't a big fan of the Roy
family take care dude if early on
they're not certain that they want the
deal they're going to negotiate hard to
try to see how much money will be on the
table they're not going to budget unless
it gets to be a stupid number
what's a stupid number what's stupid a
battalion I don't know Kendall probably
has a sense of how much leeway he has to
negotiate he's probably gotten some
direction from his father about how much
he can bargain
we're not quite closed I'm going to 120.
there are many ways to sweeten a deal
you can offer more money the number is
140. you can offer a board seat you're
on our board you're going to still run
this company independently we're not
going to interfere with you we're just
going to give you some advice from time
to time and make sure you have resources
corporate funding
it's very common for companies to have
debt they're borrowing money and using
it to invest so that they can make money
Logan has taken out a loan and to secure
the loan he has pledged his family's
stock three billion he agreed to a
condition that said if the value of the
stock went below 130 dollars a share the
bank had the right to call the loan
immediately and the bank would be repaid
from the stock it'll stabilize it will
take them from owning more than half of
the company to owning about 36 percent
of the company what I'd like to know is
what your position will be if we have a
sustained breach of the stock price and
we fall out of compliance with our debt
Covenant a loan Covenant is a condition
important to the loan and if you reach
that condition it has some implication
for when the loan is due or how much is
owed under the loan right
I know in the covet pandemic in May of
2020 a number of companies were looking
at their loan covenants and
renegotiating with their Banks because
the immediate hit to the business the
banker has to be thinking of the bank's
own shareholders he needs to make sure
that this loan is secured and that this
loan gets repaid
capital investment Kendall goes to
Stewie who's a friend but also a private
Equity investor and has a fund that may
be able to provide the money the Roy
family needs to pay back the loan
private Equity investors someone an
investor who has a fund that invests in
companies through private means to sell
it I'm going to need building stock
voting stock is stock that has voting
rights and most stock does have voting
rights I'm also going to need a board
seat what's different is the board seat
Stewie wants to be on the board because
a member of the board of directors has a
lot more information than a shareholder
does and has the ability to influence
decisions that the company is making in
a more regular fashion she's making sure
you're not selling any more of the
company from under me this is very
interesting so this is where in selling
the family stock Kendall would have had
to have gotten approval from the holding
company voting trust voting trust
agreement the family members have votes
in this voting trust and they do that by
giving votes in the trust to each of the
children Logan's ex-wife his brother and
at the start of the show there's a
discussion about giving a share to
Marcia I'm going to add Marcy to myself
a new form oh okay and my seat also to
go to her on my desk that means when he
passes away she will then have two votes
some family businesses do have these
kinds of voting trusts and do have their
children heavily engaged in the business
and there's nothing fundamentally wrong
with that here however this is a public
company with shareholders who are widely
dispersed their Pension funds and
institutional investors and people like
you and me who invest through our 401K
plans so it's not just a family business
they have to watch out for all the
shareholders
vote of no confidence with a particular
company when a CEO a chairman gets sick
you will see the stock price go down
we've seen it for example at Apple with
Steve Jobs when it was announced that he
was Ill the stock took a hit so in the
aftermath of his father's stroke Kendall
is seeing a real change in Logan and
he's worried that Logan isn't making
good decisions in running the company do
you think the real Logan would want us
to Stand By and Watch while he throws it
all away so he decides to see if he can
get the board to support him in what he
calls a vote of no confidence at the
next board meeting there's going to be a
vote of no confidence so a vote of no
confidence really isn't a legal term
it's the notion of let's take a vote and
get a sense of how we feel about this
individual are we confident in their
leadership
quite a turnout the meeting has been
called and it's clear that this is one
of the key points on the agenda and
Logan is there typically you would not
have Logan there to have this discussion
you would find a way to do it in what's
called executive session without the
person who is conflicted in this
decision there you don't get to vote and
you don't get to comment the other thing
that's unusual is clearly Kendall hasn't
done his homework he hasn't done a good
job of understanding how strongly other
directors feel about this issue and you
would not go into this vote without
having a really good idea of who was
supporting you and who wasn't right
Kendall Frank Asha Alona off the board
fired with immediate effect I don't
think you're able to do security the
firing is very interesting certainly the
CEO can fire people who are employees
but what he's really trying to do is
fire them as directors and that's not a
power that he has oh [ __ ] off but he's a
very influential and very very large
shareholder so he probably knows that he
can cause them not to be renominated and
therefore not to be up for re-election
which is sort of the same as being fired
hostile takeover strategy a bear hug is
an offer that's too good to turn down
it's an offer that is so rich that
shareholders would be furious if the
board didn't accept it so at the wedding
of his sister Kendall gives his father
the offer it's a proposal to buy waystar
for 140 a share a little bit unusual
delivering the letter to your father in
his bathroom it would be more typical
for the letter to be delivered to the
board of directors at the corporate
headquarters it also would be typical
when you get an offer of this type for
the board of directors to be very
quickly informed emergency phone board
meeting for later tonight or is that
tomorrow and also to bring together the
legal and crisis Communications team so
that they can start preparing for a
defense come on come on let's go
the financials are hard we need
political support we don't have
information to really assess how strong
this bear hug is but we do see that it
would be a significant amount in
addition to what the stock is currently
trading at and so for example in the
acquisition bid that Elon Musk made for
Twitter he put on the table about 38
percent more than where the stock was
trading 38 is a lot investors would be
very happy with 38 premium Logan and the
board are free to say no to the bear hug
but there are also other devices that
they have at their disposal I will have
the options for our poison pill defense
a poison pill is a shareholder rights
plan and it's a device that's designed
to make the acquisition much more
expensive for the acquirer corporate
merger Logan is interested in having a
much larger company and finding a way to
be almost too big to be taken over and
so he is approaching the Pierce fam
family that owns a media Empire to see
if he can do a deal with them and
acquire them we can all agree for decade
after decade your Outlets have been
essential to the functioning of our
Grand Republic
your hair if they can do this
successfully it will certainly make the
company much much larger I think we
would also like to have a conversation
about Management in the negotiation to
be acquired a company can certainly say
look we hope that when you acquire us
this is who the CEO will be who ends up
King potato but there's really no way to
hold them to it at any moment in time
the Board needs to have the flexibility
to have in place whoever they think is
the right person downsizing if indeed
the company is struggling cutting your
losses early can be a good strategy so
they have choices they can try to fix
what's wrong and invest a lot of money
accounting team analytics team or they
can look and see what can we sell off
now recoup some money Hive off the
profit Center you keep the domain name
the archive or just by shutting down
save some cost yeah you're all fired I
don't really know all of New York
employment law but yes basically they
can let employees go they can lay people
off that's within the power of a company
I'd like to thank you all for your hard
work if you have a rational reason to
believe that the action you're taking is
good for the company and it's
shareholders you can downsize we see in
Silicon Valley a lot a company will
acquire a smaller company for its
engineering Talent OR for some
intellectual property and then really
not operate the company as it was
operated before mergers and acquisitions
lovely thing about selling is everybody
gets to go off and do what they want in
a hopefully happier more satisfying life
that would make everything nice for you
I could pay you out or if you want
control inside or outside of the assets
you love
it's cool what's interesting about the
Gojo deal is Logan seems to be
interested in it in a different way and
he believes that there is some real
value there it may be that ultimately
they decide that the deal with Gojo is a
merger of equals where the Roy family
are still heavily involved on the board
and in some executive positions but
waystar will not be sold
because then the show ends I take over
dad just tell them it's going to be me
they could take the company out of our
hands step in and take the reins you
plotted a takeover what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you you lost this is about
the future this is about our future
I'm in the middle I'm turning a [ __ ]
tanker